Your ideas sound brilliant in your head,
but do they confuse readers when you
write them down? Well, after 10 years as
an English professor and writing coach,
I've found that even the simplest ideas
can be made to sound complex, and even
the most complex ideas can be made to
sound simple. It's not actually your
ideas that confuse readers. It all comes
down to the way that you structure them.
So, in this video, I'm going to show you
the coffee stain problem, which is why
readers can get so confused by your
ideas even when they ring clear in your
own mind. Then, I'm going to give you
the experience of readers as they work
their way through your text. And
finally, I'm going to show you three
types of structure in your writing. One
that you're already using, which you
should probably stop using, and two that
you can start using today. But first,
why is it that we writers fail to
recognize the patterns in our own
writing that cause difficulty with
readers? Well, think about whatever
happens whenever you're trying to
diagnose and fix problems in your own
writing. You've written a draft, and now
you're looking it over. Or maybe you
have given it to a reader, you've got
some feedback, and now you're going
through giving some corrections to it.
And so, what do you do here? Well,
here's what you think happens. All
right, you take your draft, and your
draft has all these words on it, and so
you look at those words, and you know
the meaning of those words, and you're
the one who arranged those words in that
order, and so those words in that order
give you a certain meaning. And then you
check. You say, "All right, does this
meaning that I interpret in this text
correspond to the meaning that I intend,
the one that I want to express?" And you
say, "Aha, yes, perfect. That's exactly
what I want to express." That's what
many of us think is happening in the
proofreading and revision process. But
what's really happening here is what's
called the coffee stain problem. And
here's why it fails readers. So, imagine
this. You wake up one morning and you're
getting ready to write and you pour
yourself a cup of coffee when suddenly a
great idea strikes you. And so, you rush
to your desk, you set down your coffee
cup, you reach for your pen, and in all
your excitement to start writing, you
knock over your coffee cup. And so, now
coffee is staining the paper that you
were going to write on. So, although
this paper has no words on it, that
stain, that particular shape, and the
depth, and the color, and everything, it
will still serve to remind you of the
idea that you had when you made that
stain. The problem here is when you hand
this stained paper off to readers. That
stain would mean nothing to a reader
because they weren't there in the room
with you when you had the idea. All they
have is a blank sheet of paper with a
certain shape and pattern of your coffee
stain on it. In other words, those
patterns mean nothing to your reader.
They can't use it to reconstruct the
idea that you had whenever you created
that stain. The stain will always remind
you of the brilliant idea that you had,
but it will never remind readers because
they weren't there with you when you had
the idea. So, the point of this thought
experiment is really just to show the
difficulty of editing our own work. Like
when you look at your own text, you're
not actually reading it. You're just
remembering it. When you wrote the text,
you had an idea in your mind. And then
you chose a series of words in a
particular order in order to convey that
idea. So, whenever you look at those
words in that order again, what you're
trying to do is see whether those words
correspond to the idea that you had. And
of course they do because you're the one
who chose the words. So in other words,
what we call proofreading and editing is
not really reading and interpretation,
it's more about association and
remembering the ideas that you already
had. But if you can never stand outside
yourself to get beyond your own
associations and experience the text as
your reader will, then how can we ever
edit our own work? How can you ever
predict whether a particular piece of
writing is going to work for readers?
Well, you need to do is learn the
structures and the structural locations
where readers expect to find particular
pieces of information. And you can
experience this right now. So let me
show you how this works. I'm going to
read a series of numbers for you. And
what I'd like you to do is just predict
the next number in the series. That's
it. Now I know, I know I'm breaking the
fourth wall here and I'm actually
reaching out and asking you to do
something, but I promise it'll be so.
I'm going to read you six numbers and
I'll give you a little pause, but I
recommend pausing the screen if you need
another chance. And what I'd like you to
do is just predict the next number in
the series. All right, so here's the
first series. two
three
five
seven
The next number in the series is
17 All right, here's the next series.
Predict the last number. two
three
five
eight
The next number in the series is
34. All right, last series. two
three
five
nine
four
The last number in the series is
2. Now, in case you guessed any of those
wrong and you're looking for an
explanation, the first series was a
series of prime numbers. So, that's 2 3
5 7 11 13 and the next prime number in
that series is 17. The second set of
numbers comes from the Fibonoc- Fibon-
Fibonacci? Fibonacci? Fibonocci? I've
never actually heard that word said, but
I think it's pronounced Fibonacci. The
Fibonacci series. So, you take the two
and the three and you add them together
and you get a five. And then you take
the three and the five together and you
you add them together and you get an
eight. So on and so forth and then it
would be 13 + 21 is 34. And now for that
final series of numbers, did you catch
the last number? Once again, it was 2 3
5 9 4 3 2. So, did you guess the two?
Well, if you did, then congratulations
because you just guessed my mother's
phone number. But, if that was your
mother's phone number, then the series
would seem entirely coherent to you.
But, to anybody from outside your head,
it's going to seem completely opaque.
Now, they're not just going to throw up
their hands and say, "Well, I guess
there's no pattern here." What they're
going to do is search for one and often
provide one that you didn't intend. When
you write the way that you think, you
are writing according to that third
sequence, which is entirely coherent to
you but opaque to readers. So, how can
you make your writing more coherent to
readers? Is there some universal
structure that we can use? Some master
prompt that we can give to AI? Well,
unfortunately not because that's not
really how writing works. And I know
this first hand because recently I went
back and reread my master's thesis,
which I haven't looked at for about 10
years. And at the time, I thought this
was the greatest thing that I had ever
produced. It's something I worked on
endlessly. I would wake up early before
class and work on it and I'd be working
on it all night. And one of these things
were, you know, the one of these
projects where you forget to eat. You're
working on it so much. So I was really
absorbed in this and by the time I
handed it in, it was immaculate. It was
the most perfect thing I had ever
written. And of course, when I look it
over now, 10 years later, I'm quite
embarrassed by it. Not exactly because
of the ideas, but actually because
the way that the ideas are structured. I
thought things were structured so
clearly. I thought I had just nailed the
organization. But I look over it now and
I There are parts of it that are
honestly incomprehensible to me. But
isn't that interesting? Because if
coherence is part of the text, then
surely when I look over this text, I
would be able I would be like, "Well,
there's the coherence." Right? It was
coherent when I wrote it 10 years ago,
so why is it incoherent now? It's the
same text, but there is essentially a
different reader because I've become a
different person. I've changed in that
time. In other words, coherence is not a
property of the text. Like we have this
idea that which is wrong, but we have
this idea that, you know, here's the
writer and the writer,
you know, is thinking and transcribing
that idea into text. And then that text
gets handed off to readers. And so if
the writer can make this text coherent
and clear, then the reader will look at
that text and they will perceive that
coherence. And if that was true, then
you would be able to automate this to AI
and you would be able to just read over
your text and fix it to apply some
templates or some very kind of fixed
patterns
and make it coherent. However, what the
experience that I had with my master's
thesis shows is that coherence doesn't
really work this way. It's more like
this where the idea emerges through the
relationship between the writer, the
reader, and the text. All these three
elements are in a kind of relationship
with each other and the idea emerges
from it. And so when we talk about
coherence, what we're talking about is
structure. And that structure doesn't
exist inside the text. It's not in here.
It's in the reader. And so the question
of coherence is a question of how can we
get this reader to perceive structure in
the text? And you've already had the
experience of perceiving three different
kinds of structure. So, what are those
three kinds? Well, the last kind that
you experienced with my mother's phone
number was an experience of private
structure. You didn't have any reference
for the structure that was organizing
those three elements. And so you
provided one yourself. Maybe you took a
guess, maybe you just got frustrated and
threw your hands up and said there is no
structure, but you you couldn't perceive
the structure and so the kind of
structure searching mechanism in your
brain posited one. And that's
essentially the coffee stain problem.
Now more practically in the context of
writing, that kind of structure, which
is clear to the writer and opaque to the
reader, is what results in a lot of meta
discourse. And that's why a lot of
academic prose and just really a lot of
like bad writing has a lot of these
signposts where writers are kind of
doing two jobs at once. They're both
expressing themselves and then filling
in all the logical gaps and explaining
to the reader how one idea follows from
another. And generally, readers don't
like this. It's not to say you can never
do this. This is writing. You can do
whatever you want. But just understand
that whenever your text is organized
according to your own associations in
the way that makes sense to you with a
disregard of the reader, you're either
going to abandon the reader and they're
not going to be able to use your text,
or if you want them to use your text,
then you're going to have to fill in all
the associations and logical connections
that are apparent to you but opaque to
them. So, it's not really a good way to
go. But now, the second kind of
structure that you experienced was
represented by the prime numbers. And
that's what we would call a contextual
structure because it drew on your
background information. You came to the
text and knowing some basic things about
math. And whenever you looked at the
text and you saw those numbers in that
sequence, you recognized it drawing on
your background information from a
certain kind of pattern. And that, more
practically in writing, would be
represented by something like genre
awareness. So, all readers in
non-fiction are going to expect an
introduction followed by some body
paragraphs. If you're writing a
scientific report, then you know that
your readers are going to expect an
introduction followed by the methods,
followed by the findings, followed by
the discussion. And that's not given to
them in the text, they're just drawing
on their background information about
from seeing different versions of this
kind of genre before. But now, the third
kind of structure that you experienced
was represented by the Fibonacci
sequence. And you perceived that
structure not from your own background
knowledge. Like, you might have not even
known that it was called the Fibonacci
sequence, and you certainly hadn't
memorized all the numbers in that
sequence. You just looked at the
sequence itself and the pattern kind of
emerged from the text. And in your own
writing, that's what we would call a
textual pattern. It's not one that the
reader requires any background knowledge
to recognize. It's one that's provided
to them from the text. And if you want a
visual guide to four expert patterns
that readers will easily recognize in
your text, you can get my visual guide
to expert writing. It's four pages long
and on this page I have four examples of
textual patterns with model text taken
from professional prose. So, you can
grab that down below the like button or
you can watch this video next because
it's a deep dive into those four textual
patterns. So, be sure to go check it
out.